[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
good morning to you those of you who can
hear me
the Deep state
it's trying to silence us I'm just
kidding
I'm not sure
we we are on a temporary suspension from
YouTube as we try to appeal uh it seems
someone had reported an old video of
ours on YouTube so we are trying to
appeal and we're in the appeals process
now so if you're watching this you're
probably watching this on Facebook or
you're on Twitch and I appreciate you
joining us from Facebook or twitch
here's what I want to tell you
I'm not sure exactly what YouTube did
but they were we were unable to stream
this morning
to YouTube
um it's probably because I use the word
[ __ ] a lot I'm not really sure
that maybe it I don't know uh but it's
it's only temporary we have appealed it
will win our appeal and we'll get back
on the air over on YouTube as soon as
possible here's what I want you to do
though for anyone out there that really
likes this show either you love to hear
me or you love to hate me it doesn't
matter
what I want you to do is I want you to
go to my Facebook page just go to D Tony
Michaels on Facebook it's that's that's
the link and then also go to our twitch
page as well don't forget to go to our
twitch page you're not going to want to
uh stop there so so follow us on
Facebook I know you're probably on the
Midas touch Facebook page as well but go
follow us on my page because I've been
Broadcasting
this there every single day and also
follow us on Twitch but here's what I
want you to also do if you are on
Facebook or twitch right now on your
list or Twitter and you're listening to
me I want you to go to my YouTube
channel the link is in my bio you can go
to thetonymichaels.com the YouTube
channel is there you just go to YouTube
and search the Tony Michaels podcast go
to that channel And subscribe if you're
not and set your notifications I know
that sounds weirder like Tony they
banned you they suspended you I want
them to get a message that people are
gonna come and subscribe that's what I
want to show them that I it doesn't
matter if they banish or suspend us so
if you're on YouTube or if you are on
Facebook if you're on Twitch if you're
listening to this on a directory if you
have downloaded this on a directory go
to YouTube right now right now even
click off the show you got a few minutes
because I'm gonna tell you what's gonna
happen today we got a great interview
with Dakota Adams Stuart Rhodes is a
strange son he's going to talk about all
the oath keeper news that has been going
on the last two weeks we also we also
have bonehead of the week Gabe's not
here today but he will be here in
bonehead of the week because we did a
deep State thing a deep fake thing and
we pre-recorded it is what we did so
it'll play today
so we have a we have a lot of stuff
today to get to
um we have again we have Dakota Von
Adams Stewart Rhodes is a strange Sun
we've got a lot of oat keeper news the
last two weeks that we went through with
with Dakota and he gave us his input on
what that means for Stuart Rhodes and
Kelly surreal and some of the others uh
proud boys and oath keeper trials and
rather the question rather Stuart Rhodes
will go all the way to trial or if he'll
take a deal so Dakota gets into that so
you're not going to want to miss that
right now if you're listening to me on
Facebook
twitch on any directory out there
our Twitter go over to YouTube right now
type in the Tony Michaels podcast And
subscribe and click the notification
button and let's Show YouTube that you
guys want me to be on YouTube as well
you want me to be heard as far and as
loud as we can now we've been working on
a new website uh we're working on it
it's gonna take several weeks to get
this website finished that takes a while
to build these things but we are working
on a new website
and that website is going to be a
membership website where you guys have
access to all the content all of it no
matter what YouTube wants to ban no
matter what they say I can and cannot
say on a website I can say whatever the
[ __ ] I want and they can't stop me right
so if you are a loyal Avid listener here
we are going to be rolling out a website
over the next few weeks that you guys
will be able to be members of but the
most important thing is you will be able
to go watch the live stream there as
well and we're gonna try to set up a
live chat like we do on Facebook and
YouTube we're not sure exactly how that
works yet but we're going to try to find
a plug-in that is very secure so you
guys can chat even on our website so
that's what we're working on right now
we're we're still building it it's still
in the works so if you're listening
right now and I know you guys uh come
here every day and you want to hear
what's going on for two hours every
single day and really honestly that to
all the loyal audience out there that
has come to this stream even though
we're banned on YouTube
um either you're on Twitch or Facebook
or Twitter I want to tell you that we
appreciate all of you guys tuning in
every single day it means so much to us
we would not do it if this audience was
not growing the way that it's growing
it's growing rapidly now we're gaining
Steam and really that's what keeps us
going and your support means more than
anything and I don't just mean money and
really if you could if you could support
us monetarily that would help out a lot
that helps us get to the website quicker
really honestly that helps us get to
three hours a day because I feel like
there's a lot of times there's a lot of
things we don't get to talk about with
you folks
and give you our insight into what's
going on with these topics because we
only have two hours there's so much news
that we can't even get to it within two
hours in a day we really need three but
we we have to have we have to have
something to justify that and boy do we
start to have the audience to justify
that so I appreciate every single one of
you every single one of you even the
haters even the haters I'm so glad that
you're here I love that you love to hate
me and and I'm so glad that you're
hearing you come watch every day and I
know that sounds weird that you know I
would say I I like that the haters are
here I do I truly do like that the
haters are here because one day we will
possibly change their minds they'll
they'll wake up a bit and they'll
understand that what they were thinking
was you know delusional nonsense that
maybe they found on on Facebook or an
eight Chan 4chan something like that
but they can come here and they can talk
and they can chat with you guys every
single day two hours a day we want to go
to three we gotta have we gotta have
that website in place we gotta have the
memberships in place and we're not sure
exactly what that looks like maybe you
guys could uh give us some suggestions
get in the comments here in in the video
go to Twitter uh send me some comments
there and tag me in them tell me what
you tell me what you would want in a
membership do you want like a newsletter
do you want like articles you want
special videos we can do special videos
we can do like a town hall event where
it's hey you get an invitation to a town
hall and you get to ask me questions
um on on a Town Hall event now there's
all sorts of things that we could do
there's all sorts of things that we
could do
um but I want you guys to have the
things that you want from this
membership and this website and
ultimately I want you to be able to see
our content every single day no matter
what platform decides to ban us whether
it be temporary or or permanent so make
sure make sure right now to go to the
tonymichaels.com follow us everywhere
follow us on Facebook if you haven't
already
go follow us there make sure you go and
you download you have to download every
single one of these episodes on your
favorite directories whether it be apple
Spotify Google
wherever you get your
your podcast download it there and leave
us a review why you're following us and
follow us on Twitter because we do the
bone hint of the week every single week
Tony the Tony Mike at
tonymichaelspod.com
and if you want to support us monetarily
you see the link below support.d Tony
Michaels pod.com or the QR code that
support that Tony
michaelspod.com or use the QR code the
link is in the description if you're
seeing this video and also don't forget
let's Show YouTube who we are let's show
me we are go over and subscribe and
leave your notification
let's pile on the subscriptions over
there one last thing before I go we have
these new dark Brandon t-shirts oh my
God they're flying off the shelves you
guys love this design it is a new
exclusive Tony Michaels podcast design
for dark Brandon uh everyone everyone
loves the t-shirts there's red there's
black there's heavy metal color
and there's also coffee mugs we got
stickers and we have hoodies as well so
go over to
store.thetonymichaels.com and find the
dark Brandon merch that helps us out a
lot you know what the thing I like about
the dark Brandon merch is that you we
get something you guys get something we
you get to support us and then you get
to wear around this cool dark Brandon
design on a t-shirt show all your Trump
hump and friends that's why I like the
red one because it's red you know he's
evil he's satanic I don't know it starts
up a conversation right
so go to store.d Tony michaels.com and
get your dark Brandon merch there thank
you for all the support we really do
appreciate it
um again we just couldn't do it without
you guys
coming every single day not just not
just listening but you guys engage you
engage with this show you engage with
each other you I I think I think a lot
of you have made great friends in the
chat and that means a lot that the
community is here that you guys are
talking and you're engaging in your
democracy you know how much that means
because I know that that is what is
going to keep us from going into a
fascist state
is to engage with each other even the
people who
fake Gabe over there on Facebook uh even
even even engaging with people who don't
necessarily see our point of view
because that's important we have to
engage in our democracy it is so vitally
important and that's why I do this show
and we can grow this audience imagine
having 20 30 000 people watching all at
once talking to each other having these
conversations making friends making a
community I think we can do that I think
we can do that and with your help I know
we can I know we can I know we can
here's what's gonna happen today on the
show we're gonna have a great interview
with Dakota Von Adams
talking about The Oath Keepers and
Stuart Rhodes and his TR his push to try
to push back his trial but he's going to
trial and Dakota's going to give us what
he thinks Stewart is going to do rather
he's going to cave and take a deal or
rather he's going to go all the way now
don't miss that interview that is next
right after the break and then after the
interview we have bonetta of the week me
and Gabe go through all the boneheads
that you voted for because you vote
you decide we go through the bone of the
week so stick around thanks for joining
us here on the Tony Michaels podcast it
means a lot even though we're banned
we're banned from the tubes of you
everyone stick around right after this
break Dakota Von Adams and then after
the next break bonehead of the week
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after these messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back from the break we have our
guest here Dakota Von Adams the
astranged son of Stewart Rhodes the
founder of the oak Keepers it's been a
regular guest here when Oath Keepers
news
hits and drops and we've had um several
pieces of oathkeeper news over the last
few weeks Dakota thanks for joining us
again here on the Tony Michaels podcast
thanks for having me as always
all ever eager to inflict
my perspective on the oath Keeper's
childhood on your wider audience yes
absolutely well we love your perspective
here because it's it seems that you know
more in your experience uh being there
with Steward as The Oath Keepers became
the organization that eventually led to
part of the Insurrection you were right
there so you've seen the inside you know
exactly who these people are so let's
start um from a couple weeks ago because
we on August 30th Stuart Rhodes went to
court for a motion to delay his trial
um he lost that bid in court now it
seems like Stewart is trying to create a
tactic here and I even said on my show
before that I thought the judge would
buy into this tactic because a lot of
times what a defense team will do is
they will go to court for a motion
saying oh we have new Council so we have
to go have time to look at Discovery to
act actually do a defense at trial and
it seems like Stuart was trying to
deploy that tactic where he fires one
legal team hires another to get a judge
to delay this child the judge did not
buy into that is that kind of what you
took from that decision yes also in
there uh his filing is
I think very harsh for it being that
tactic and I think there are elements of
it that his legal team was probably not
aware of because he basically calls them
incompetent buffoons who have abandoned
and betrayed him
and especially as salty at the concept
that they have other things going on in
their lives or are able to leave for a
long weekend vacations ahead of the
trials while he's in jail which
um is something that he should have
thought of before committing allegedly a
very major crime
and it's
very much throwing his previous or
current because he was not allowed to
ditch them at this stage in the game
legal counsel throwing them completely
under the bus
in favor of this new guy extracted from
Louisiana but you do believe that this
is a tactic from Stuart just to delay
um because he's he's seeing that there
isn't much of a defense for the evidence
that's being laid against him
um by not only not only the government
but also the January 6 select committee
which uh we'll get into here in a bit
um on on that but I want to show you
because the day after that that was
August 30th September 1st we got news of
more oath keeper
um um proceedings and there was an
indictment that was given against Kelly
surreal
um Kelly surreal was not only seemed
like Stewart's right-hand gal but maybe
even a girlfriend at some point but but
the most significant thing is when
Stewart was indicted and was detained
and arrested
um she kind of declared herself the
leader of the Oath Keepers right
because she she is actually an attorney
she has represented The Oath Keepers and
several other groups for The Oath
Keepers in particular she is an attorney
but she's been charged with four counts
uh on her own indictment she's the only
defendant in this so she's not drawn
into the conspiracy that Stewart's on
the first count as conspiracy to
obstruct an official proceeding uh the
second count is obstruction of official
proceeding and aiding and abetting and
the third count is entering and
remaining in a restricted building or
grounds now those three charges we've
seen on these other cases um right but
the fourth count I think is very um
significant on her indictment and I
think is the reason why she's on her own
indictment here
it says uh account for is obstruction of
justice but the uh the the more
underlining charges tampering with
documents um that's really bad when an
attorney is yeah charged with tampering
with documents that is a pretty hardcore
and I believe
um I'm not I'm not certain I haven't
looked a lot at her indictment so is
this related to the fake electors push
well you know that is unclear at this
point so
um I'm not sure if this tampering of
documents is before or after January 6.
it's very unclear uh to me where this
light lays out but you had spoke before
that you said that um Stewart believes
that this is a ploy by the government to
get her to turn is that is that your
view of it
yes and that is uh
that is the accusation laid out in his
uh desperate filing to fire his current
lawyers replace them and then get
himself an extension so that his new
lawyer can review Discovery is
[Music]
the one of the points is the allegation
that the government is filing spurious
and on Shaky Ground would be a good it
would be a good term uh indictments on
everyone associated with Oath Keepers to
make sure that they can apply
pressure to sign a deal to everybody on
their Witnesses list and I think that
having her being indicted on her own
indictment actually does say that yes
they are looking for her to cooperate
they are giving her leeway by not doing
a superseding indictment and bringing
her into Stuart and the other Oath
Keepers case
um giving her leeway to cooperate in
that form and fashion I think actually
the other thing that is very significant
about Kelly surreal being on her own
indictment too is she has committed
crimes outside of what The Oath Keepers
other indictment those crimes were
committed yes that's very significant I
think
um and I think it's significant in that
the cooperation because what is more to
me about Kelly surreal the story of hers
because when uh they actually
went and served the search warrants and
they actually served the arrest warrants
and they arrested The Oath Keepers
Stuart being one of them and you know he
challenged it he was in detention in
Oklahoma he tried to go to Texas they
finally sent him to DC you know that was
a whole Challenge and I know your family
was involved in making sure that he
wasn't let out on like an ankle bracelet
or something because the guy has known
history of wanting to evade and and get
away from Cross even International
borders to try to to try to skate
indictment and and criminal charges he's
he's done these things before I know
you've dug the ditches yourself
um for some of these Escape tunnels so
um your own hands have done this so yeah
more to the point he wanted to be
released to the supervisory custody of
relatives with ties to Sovereign citizen
activists who spoke at area Nation
conferences right so white supremacist
is what you're saying yeah he wanted to
release the supervising custody of white
supremacists and Oath Keepers support
orders with yeah well and I and I think
that's the part of the story of Kelly
surreal because when he was indicted and
detained she almost immediately said I'm
now the leader of the national Oath
Keepers right
um the National Organization not the an
individual chapter and very quickly
right very quickly she moved away from
that
um and she said no I'm just an attorney
right I'm just an attorney just the
general counsel uh I'm just the general
counsel I'm not dating Stuart I think he
just wanted somewhere to sleep which is
probably the coldest
coldest public breakup by text I've ever
seen in my life
and I will probably see more about that
as time goes on she hasn't responded to
me on Twitter when I asked how she dealt
with the smell while he was living with
her oh really so you never you never got
a report back bro
she's she's never gotten back to me on
that ah well maybe maybe eventually
she'll answer that question she's got
she seems she's going to be pretty busy
over the next couple years uh with this
indictment but so but the Kelly surreal
story obviously does not end with just
her being the acting present and not
being the acting president something
happened she was active she was right
there in the thick of it because they
wouldn't be able to indict her on four
counts if they didn't have some sort of
evidence against her my personal take is
that Kelly Sorel is the Bridge or
overlap between in one of the points of
overlap between the paramilitary
operation on January 6 to delay or
disrupt
the Electoral accounting and create
cover of Chaos in that and also was
involved in the legalistic attempts
to overturn the election because she's
in other prongs yes and that's where her
association with her Association for
lawyers with lawyers for Trump is so she
is the connection point between Oath
Keepers
and other prongs of Team Trump's
attempts to overturn the election in my
personal view I'm probably going to see
more about that I mean that's that's uh
that's some speculation there but I
think um it's worse it's worth visiting
that speculation because we're seeing
more and more as we watch uh tapes in
Coffee County Georgia where people were
led into to tamper with the voting
machines um you had Tina Peters a county
clerk uh now indicted and now uh her
co-conspirator it seems in this act of
stealing uh data and tampering with
actually tampering with voting machine
it's funny the people accusing people
tampering voting machines they're
actually the ones that were voted uh
tampering voting machines how funny is
that but they'd stop the my pillow guy
Mike Lindell in a Hardee's drive-through
in Minnesota and took his phone in the
case to do with that so I just just I
was just talking about that on Twitter
the other day as all of these militia
Yahoo's and these guys obsess over the
feds coming to take them down are being
assassinated being ambushed like Stuart
would roll around with a folding stock
AK stuck between the center console and
the driver's seat of his car so he could
pull it out and fire out the window like
a bank heist movie but he would
intentionally frequently put himself in
a perfect Ambush Channel
by putting himself in a concrete Chute
with no escape to get french fries
all these guys that Mike Lindell is not
going to be the last one stopped
in a drive-through priorities is going
to be the site of many federal takedowns
over the coming years because all of
these dudes are paranoid and armed and
they think they're badasses because they
took it they took a defensive driving
course once and learned how to do a
Bootleggers uh u-turn
and they're all going to put themselves
in the concrete vehicular Ambush trowel
to get their hamburgers and they're just
going to get snapped up like that over
and over is my first of all prediction
you know that that is not a bad
prediction probably that's a probably a
pretty good one because they like to
emulate Trump and Trump loves fast food
so that is possibly you know the
connection point there I think Trump
might just like fast food because it's
uh modern conservative thing that
they're all obsessed with it all that's
all they that's all they do is say oh
God they all go to Hardee's for
hamburgers right right well because they
got the hot chicks on the commercials of
course I mean why wouldn't you eat a
Hardee's Burger taste so good because of
their commercials but you know what's
funny about them emulating Trump is
Stewart tried to do this in his last
motion he tried to say hey I want a
special master I don't know what I don't
know I don't know to be his special
master or what this uh fetish is with
Trump but
Stewart's classified information needs
reviewed evidence in his trial because
so my thing is so Edward Tarpley Edward
Tarpley Jr the guy who was being brought
on as the shiny new toy lawyer to
replace the tired boring old lawyers who
are not magically getting Stuart's ass
out of the fire he's getting also a
brief writing advice from a Montana
libertarian party political figure
you're with a lot of ties to white
supremacist groups in his youth Roger
Roots is a really good political piece
about that and he I think the call for a
special Master is Edward tarpley's
brainchild I predict
we're going to see more weird filings
with Tarpley fingerprints on them
because I don't think asking for a
special Master for no other reason than
to emulate Trump is something that
Stewart would think of
it's the kind of thing he would go along
with if somebody else broached it but I
don't think that'd be the kind of thing
that Stewart would come up with on his
own off the top of his head so I believe
that's a Tarpley idea which is nothing
but to create a popular association with
Trump and getting headlines so it's just
a media boy basically yeah so we're
playing in there we're playing we're
playing into Stuart's hands here which
they're really not um that great of
hands I mean no because really the judge
knocked this down and squashed it like a
cockroach like he's like a special
Master what the hell are you talking
about confused and uh questioning if the
lawyers are acting in good faith right
right well right and I think and I think
that's a detriment to the lawyer's
reputation that are actually a defending
Steward here and these other uh January
6 defendants speaking of January 6
defendants the uh the Cheeto desk
mobster the grand Grandpa Poopypants
himself was on Hugh Hewitt's show today
I want to show you this because we have
talked about uh stochastic terrorism and
what the threat is and here he is now he
phones it in he's not like on video
video you know this guy's probably
sitting in just a thousand pounds of Big
Mac grease and Cheeto dust here so it's
not like he can you know be in front of
the camera that would take hours to get
him all you know dolled up to get him in
front of a camera in that photo shoot
that law and prompts to long range
camera photo shoot from the golf course
where he and his co-conspirators alleged
are wandering around trying to get their
stories straight
um not one of those men have an ass
yeah kind of astounding right well
they're all strapped into girdles and
they all have the ass of Hank Hill well
it looks like it looks like they took an
a frog stood it up and put pants on it I
mean is what you're saying now I
actually had Michael Cohen on um this
week and we talked about what the hell
he was doing on the golf course and
Michael Cohen actually didn't think that
that Golf Course meaning was anything
other than Donald Trump trying to figure
out how to get a Saudi tournament at
this golf course you know because he
probably owes the Saudis
um some kind of golf tournament I mean
that's why he traded you know maybe
maybe just maybe the unclassified
quote-unquote documents that he
Declassified with his big mac stained
hands I don't know it's very unclear
what that meeting was about but Michael
Cohen did say that sources tell him that
he did make meet with two attorneys and
the reason why he did meet with two
attorneys because he didn't want to be
spotted meeting at a law office as some
of this defense legal defense fund
um news is coming down in this Grand
injury is happening he doesn't want to
appear that he thinks he has criminal
exposure which he most certainly does
but listen to how he makes this call it
sounds so familiar Dakota from Donald
Trump himself there was a time in
December in 2020 when he knew he was
going to lose the state electors had
been certified and he knew that they
were going to come to Washington and the
Congress was going to have to certify
him and Joe Biden was going to be was
going to be the president of the United
States so he had to make this he said oh
come January 6 it's going to be wild
right and that's why you are such a
moment in history because Stuart Rhodes
came The Oath Keepers came the proud
boys
eggs in that basket that's right on
Trump that's right well here he is doing
it again listen to this on Hugh Hewitt's
show today listen you know the old
saying uh prosecutor can indict a ham
sandwich if they want to I'm just asking
if there is such a prosecutor and they
indict you would that deter you from
running for president it again I don't
think the people of the United States
would stand for it and as you know if a
thing like that happened I would have no
prohibition against running you know
that you've already I do and that's what
I want people to understand that would
not take you out of the Arena it would
not but I think if it happened I think
you'd have problems in this country the
likes of which perhaps we've never seen
before I don't think the people of the
United States would stand for it what
kind of problems Mr President I think
they'd have big problems big problems I
just don't think they'd stand for it
they will not they will not sit still
and stand for this ultimate of hoaxes
what the [ __ ] does it mean that a
prosecutor can indict a ham sandwich if
he wants to well I mean it means that
that they can get a grand jury to indict
anyone for anything based on any
evidence whatsoever which I mean it you
know in in um you know in context might
be true but in this context it's not the
actual what is actually happening right
so like no like like in this context
this is not not the prosecution uh
process or indicting a ham sandwich the
ham sandwich committed a lot of bucking
crimes and there's a hell of a ton of
evidence just a mountain of evidence
that the ham sandwich that we're talking
about committed a lot of [ __ ] crime
not just on January 6 but up the lead up
to with his election uh defense fraud
um and now with the classified documents
so and even the election tampering that
he did after the election in the states
like Georgia so this ham sandwich has
been committing a lot of crime so it's
easy for a grand jury and the prosecutor
to indict this ham sandwich in
particular but I think this is so
important because you've talked about
this before where they really are trying
to call on people to commit uh terrorism
and um and we watched this week not
going back to fast food too much but we
watched even someone
some lunatic in a clown wig I'm not
making this up a clown went into a Dairy
Queen and tried to with a gun and when
he was arrested he said the reason why
he was out doing this is he was
undercover and he was trying to make
Donald Trump the president King what of
the United States whatever the [ __ ] that
is and he was going to kill Democrats
and liberals now
um this is all calls
from the right wing and from the Trump
camp where they call him the Maga King
the Maga King this the Maga King that
Donald Trump Jr is always putting out
emails and text messages on this stuff
and then Donald Trump goes on Hugh
Hewitt's show today which in the
right-wing media is not considered uh
far right like Steve Bannon or anything
else
um uh Hugh Hewitt is a mainstream
right-wing he's generic right you see
what his vanilla flavor and right he is
humoring this kind of
incitement to violence again and he just
kept you kind of saw it in that clip he
was trying to bring Trump back around to
you can totally run for president he's
like yes but also incitement inciting a
riot oh yeah well and he wants to he's
calling on them and this isn't just him
saying oh America's America is going to
be pissed he's saying all my people out
there all my sheep you need to be mad if
I'm indicted you need to create this
situation where it's very hard now
here's my opinion and I've said this the
last few weeks because Lindsey Graham
did this and a few other prominent
politicians have said there's going to
be riots in the streets that's how they
put it my feeling is and we've talked
about this before is there will be uh
small pockets of violence but the the
problem with the midterm and the
indictment is where do they go to
overturn it there's no one place Focus
there's no lightning rod for violence
he's just putting a generalized call of
violence out there that like maybe a
street shooter
or
someone with a bomb will act on maybe
people being drawn by if there's a
well-organized enough push you could see
people drawn by local influencers lower
down in the right-wing media sphere to
attack any democrat-controlled or not
explicitly Maga controlled Institution
and possibly this would create energy
that could be channeled into an attack
on the election infrastructure oh yeah
but you but do you think yeah but here's
the thing do you actually think that
um the the paramilitary universe is so
tight-knit that they can create somehow
in such a form and fashion
um in such a short amount of time
um and create this situation where they
can almost do another January 6
somewhere I I really probably not
another January 6th but we'll probably
see a bit of targeted violence I think
that's probably where it's going to go
is there's going to be this like what
happened on the sixes there might be
back Channel Communications with
explicit instructions that cannot be
traced back to people
uh further up the chain that's where
we've got that weird alleged uh phone
call between Stewart and the go-between
who refused to put him on directly with
Trump the one that I suspect to be Roger
Stone or Michael Flynn but you also had
the rioters on January 6th and The Oath
Keepers team two monitoring Trump's
Twitter for things they can interpret as
further instructions and you're probably
going to see low-level grifting Moga
influencers
setting themselves up as The Interpreter
and organizers interpreters foreign
organizers of the enacting of Trump's
will and then they're going to direct
uh violence against
local targets and kind of a cellular
gorilla fashion we've seen a little bit
of that already with the different magu
groups like proud boys and Patriot
prayer uh storming school board meetings
and be and like threatening violence at
hospitals and libraries right well even
over gay rights issues yeah right well
even Patriot front going out and
marching in the streets and having their
little
um line dance kind of
which seems weird but they have these
videos that have surfaced on the
internet of this what appears to be line
dancing but they're actually trying to
do riot training or something yeah
provider control training it's really
weird it's well it's
they're pretty raw newbies and I think
that was partially that wasn't
recruiting
I was that that what that's what makes
the color guard in the background make
sense is all the guys standing around
with the flag because that was partially
recruiting a propaganda video that was
meant to be disseminated
on darker corners of the internet were
shown to prospective recruits and so
they had to go kind of low power on the
sparring element to make it look good
right but I talked about this on my
little tiny barely existent live stream
a while ago which everyone which
everyone should go follow by the way but
we'll get it we'll get into a Shameless
plug here soon but the uh there there
are videos you can look up on YouTube
especially the US Marine Corps and the
Very sophisticated uh South Korean
military police uh Riot training riot
control training drill that very clearly
demonstrates what they're building up
towards and everything they're training
for
um once you are well practiced enough at
it is a legitimate tactic for fighting a
very large crowd of angry people and
also shows that Patriot front is betting
heavily on being on the side of or
operating with the backing of the police
and the local government when they go
out to crush protests
which is kind of funny because they've
actually been arrested and found in the
back of you know they've been found
sweaty in the back of hot U-Hauls all
around the country and even again been
detained and rested for it but you did
every FBI yes right right which is uh
local police have let them go with no
charges multiple times in the past after
they attacked bystanders under cover of
uh smoke grenades during their marches
right well and we'll see what happens
with this Patriot front and some of
these other obscure groups
um you know I call them the plastic
Shield Brigade because that's kind of
what they are but I want to go back to
you what you said about the um the
communication on Oath Keepers on January
6th because today the January 6
committee and they seem to be signaling
uh about Stewart's trial and The Oath
Keepers trial here because Stewart's
trial is uh in just in a few weeks but
the the proud boys trial is put up until
December
um so it seems like January 6 is kind of
you know taunting uh about the trial
that is going to happen here in the next
keeping it fresh in everyone's Minds
right put a voice to it like this
god-awful chortling that we get from
Milwaukee from the walkie-talkie audio
intercepts right and that's what I'm
going to show here so let's show this
video of the walkie-talkie and then uh
let's talk about what is in this because
it's kind of confusing what they're
saying but let's let's listen here CNN
just said that they evacuated all
members of Congress into a safety room
there's no safe place in the United
States for any of these [ __ ]
right now let me tell you
they understand that we are not joking
around
military principle 105 military
principle 105 cave means grave
Trump just tweeted
please support our Capitol Police they
are on our side do not harm them
that's saying a lot by what he didn't
say he didn't say not to do anything to
the congressman
well he did not ask him to stand down
he's just said uh stand by the Capitol
Police they are on our side and they are
good people so uh it's getting real down
there I got it on TV and it's um it's
looking pretty freaking radical to me
CNN said that Trump has egged this on
that he is egging it on and that he is
watching the country burn two weeks
before he leaves office he is not
leaving office I don't give a [ __ ] what
they say
we are in the main dome right now we are
rocking it they're throwing grenades
they're freaking shooting people with
paintballs but we're in here
be safe be safe God bless and Godspeed
and keep going get it Jess do your [ __ ]
this is what we [ __ ] lived up for
everything we [ __ ] trained for
okay Dakota okay Dakota so so there's
several things there's a lot to pick
apart here
um first off who's Jess do you do you
know who no yes I don't I don't know who
any is I don't know okay these people
well I really razzmatize myself more
with the stack but yeah well I didn't I
just didn't know if there was like a
particular reason why someone called out
Jess but I want to go back to another
thing that someone said in the very
beginning they talked about 105 105
military
105.3 or something what the hell is that
what I can't find that [ __ ] anywhere
military uh there's
hey there's documents on
uh evidence gathering for a trial
and that's 105 on the list in that but I
can't find whatever list of military
principles they're referring to is
something uh informal that's not indexed
by Google because I can't find
references to it anywhere and it doesn't
sound familiar to me at all from any of
the Tactical [ __ ] that I was around when
I was growing up
Keepers land it just sounds like this
guy saying some [ __ ] is that what it
could be like their equivalent of like
when people first started talking about
uh
like
pretending like rule number 34 was part
of a vast list of established rules for
the internet like I think he might have
just made that [ __ ] up off the top of
his head and made it sound like it was
from
uh list of military principles
that's much larger and then he kind of
laughed like uh
one of the one of the characters from
the Mass Effect games is that exact same
laugh that's kind of disconcerting you
know people in the audience will know
which one
it's just oh so yeah these guys uh well
very clearly uh caught themselves out on
audio
that their intention was to harm or kill
members of Congress that they thought
they had Trump's blessing as long as he
didn't explicitly order or otherwise
that they were keeping an eye on his
Twitter to see what he was telling the
mob which like I said previously uh
demonstrates that Communications between
them and anybody else
and the uh coup conspiracy chain of
command had been severed on the day of
to preserve the diability right and that
they were just relying on Twitter
so so this is the same his Twitter
account is basically the same thing he
just did on Hugh Hewitt I mean yes there
people are going to be looking to it for
cues and clues on how to act and the
messaging that they're getting is go
nuts if I'm indicted and then we'll see
if he starts painting a specific Target
right he could be in he could start
trying to incite specifically against
uh federal police right or department or
federal department of justice so you're
saying it as it heats up on him he could
call and make these these little cat
calls uh for these terrorists to create
acts in these particular ways because we
watched it on this tape the other thing
too that I want to ask you about this
because I was kind of confused because
there's some people that are at home
watching TV and there's some people that
are like in the Rotunda so what is this
little walkie-talkie thing is this like
an app that they're using or what do you
know what this is how they're I actually
do not know I think it is
I think it's a walkie-talkie app that
they're using because it doesn't sound
like radio communication right because I
know uh previously Oath Keepers had a
bunch of Trello channels set up for uh
using uh truckers to report on like
military movements that they saw across
the country that was a thing that was
going on for a little bit Yeah because
they even they they had [ __ ] like down
in Texas where they thought Obama was
taking over the Texas or some [ __ ]
yeah trade home my personal beginning of
the end for believing in the apocalypse
because it got so ridiculous oh really
that's that's what did it yeah Jade Helm
was one of the turning points yep oh I
see I see well and they use this same
kind of app
um when they had like the truckers
Convoy in Canada when they were blocking
them yes
they were doing the same type of teams
type of thing and there was the um what
was the what was the the ranch the ranch
thing that kind of came in the uh
um there was there was some um
can't think of it now damn
um anyways there was people that were
infiltrating their little group chat
it's almost like Twitter spaces kind of
thing where one person speaks at a time
and it's almost in like a walkie-talkie
thread type thing so I think that's what
this is from but the January 6 select
committee chose to instead of show the
actual app thread I guess they just
chose to play the audio and then show
the video from the Rotunda which again
it's uh the j6c holding back Jessica uh
holding back
information for their upcoming sessions
right like I think it's highly
suspicious that they didn't include our
not suspicious but indicative indicative
of
further focus on Oath Keepers and
paramilitary groups in the uh next round
of hearings that are coming up so let me
ask you one more thing before we go
because we're running out of time here
um do you think and I'm gonna ask you
again I've asked you this before I think
a couple times do you think Stuart
Rhodes will go we'll go all the way and
he will go to trial all the way to a
jury decision
I wrote about this a little bit for my
sub stack that I will plug at the very
end but my opinion is that if Stewart
um
feels that he has been personally
betrayed by Trump and the manga Circle
in some way then that will give him the
psychological clearance
to plead out and make a deal otherwise
he will go down swinging because he'll
be anticipating some um some kind of
future conservative Red Wave or
president
setting him free so that he can emerge
from prison Like a Phoenix and go back
to a resurgent career in militia
[ __ ] or politics depending on what
strikes his fancy right he would be he
would be one of Trump's top generals or
something of the sort not or maybe not
even Trump maybe DeSantis or some future
figure but if he is specifically burned
and people start calling him a informant
like if Trump implied he were an
informant or DeSantis did then he would
be likely to plead out otherwise he's
going to make his trial as much of a
spectacle as possible as much of a
public relations thing as possible get
in the headlines make a huge amount of
noise
make crazy filings
and go down swinging and make it into a
circus
so circus it is I think that's what
we're gonna see I don't think we're
gonna see him thinking anyone's turning
I think the special Master is more an
occasion that he thinks he's on Trump's
side here and Trump is on his side
possibly but I guess I guess we'll be
teasing of Pardons for January 6th
defendants at Trump rallies is doing
exactly what it's intended to do it's a
dangling hope right dangling hope in
front of
uh January 6 defendants to tell them not
to flip and it's not that and you're not
talking about the insurrectionists that
we're breaking windows and walking
around with podiums you're talking about
the people who had communication all the
way to the top the people who were not
cannon fodder and there's a pretty great
interview with uh Mike Giglio where he
interviewed Stewart a week before he was
arrested where Stewart seemed kind of
despondent about how Trump has abandoned
the other January six defendants hasn't
contributed financially to their defense
or really spoken out in favor of them
and said that he felt like oathkeepers
was used as cannon fodder and then
abandoned once they were no longer
useful
and that's really true of the rest of
the crowd if
he ends up on that emotional track again
he might flip but as long as
that uh promise of a pardon and eventual
return the status as a free man is
dangled in front of him
he'll he'll stay on the train even if he
even if Trump goes down he could bet on
DeSantis or a future Red Wave because
like a lot of conservatives he thinks
that he is in a sizable majority well
and that we have a temporary aberration
of liberal governance in the country
well you know it's it's uh it's crazy to
think that he believes that he's some
sort of hero to these people
um I I believe he's gonna be the exact
opposite
um again I I I hope that we see what
this trial does in the next couple weeks
we're also that same week that Stewart's
trial starts we're gonna have the
January 6th select committee hearings
restarting uh I think that's no
coincidence right I I agree with you I
think that's why they dropped the video
of the walkie-talkie today I think
they'll be dropping more videos I think
they're trying to get the attention to
the American people what's coming in the
next few weeks Dakota thanks for joining
us give us one last plug here of your uh
Shameless plug where you want people to
find you
um just all the things all of the things
are at dakotatheadams.com you go to the
you go there you see the link tree and
then there's my tiny YouTube channel my
insignificant live stream and my sub
stack along with social media great well
thanks a lot Dakota for joining us again
thanks for all the insight into Stuart
Rhodes mind as much as you probably
don't like to go there but
um in this world what I've got to work
with and it's already there taking up
mental space I might as well use it
that's right well thank you Dakota for
joining us everyone stick around we will
be right back right after this break
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babble mag
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bonehead of the week bonehead of the
week welcome welcome to this edition of
bonehead of the week we are in some sort
of parallel universe where Gabe Sanchez
is here but he's not here
it's I think it's called recording is
what it is yeah Soros feature yes it is
ai ai Gabe is what this is no I'm just
kidding we're recording this in advance
but um you guys know that because you
voted early this week we had the poll
out on Twitter at Tony Michael's pod go
follow us on Twitter you can vote there
you can also vote for us here on YouTube
at the Tony Michaels pod so if you are
over on the Midas touch Network channel
come over and follow us on Tony Michael
ifato watch us live bonehead of the week
every single Friday in the second hour
and if you're on the mightiest touch
Network right now go ahead and click
that subscribe button there as well
welcome to Bone end of the week no
matter where you're watching it is all
recorded this week yeah that's okay
Gabe's got important deep State bunker
work to do I think is that what's going
on deep deep deep State deep underground
deep underground bunker work deep
so like Soros has me on a not just a tip
like all the way oh okay good just oh
okay good good good well we have we have
a bunch of
the dick talk we had a lot of dicks to
get to uh this week at bone end of the
week who's our contestants here Gabe
holy moly we got I know we got some
[ __ ] boneheads here we got Mike
Lindell holy [ __ ] Instagram yeah Rudy
kaluti my hair is draining Giuliani
Grandpa farty mcsharty Rudy Giuliani as
I call him yeah what a great set of
boneheads this week I'm excited we have
we also have a special Alpha cook
and and a dishonorable mention he's
pretty much always a dishonorable
mention yeah just sometimes other people
work their way up ahead of it yeah yeah
yeah sometimes yeah they usually just
like buy a smidge that they're like ah
this guy is even more right of an
[ __ ] right because this guy every
week could be on this list or DM Alpha
Geck I mean this gay
everybody hates him like everybody I
mean I think even his daughters hate him
right his dog has to definitely oh yeah
and the cat hates him even worse but
let's get to our our original
contestants Rudy colludy Grandpa farty
mccharty Rudy Giuliani is on the list
Gabe did he say something about
September 11th is that why he's on the
list this week is that yeah
America's mayor said that uh September
11th was one of the greatest I think is
what he said it was one of the greatest
moments yeah of his life now I remember
I actually think I actually which is
definitely a take it's definitely a take
he's something he's something
um when he says when he says that uh
it's the best day and the worst day and
I remember this uh this video because he
said this on September 11th right he was
being interviewed
um of course uh they were talking about
September 11th uh let me see if I can uh
find this great piece of tape I'm like I
I imagine that beard but when I heard
Rudy say this I was like oh this is is
this like Charles Dickens like it was
the best of times it was the worst
like Rudy giuliani's just giving I think
it was away in that he was on or
something like that wow
looky here we got the Tweet here it's
actually from our page podcast
um you can follow us at the Tony
Michaels podcast because we bring you
the breaking news there we hold the
media accountable
my Rudy Giuliani describes 911
as the greatest day of his life that was
what I think I wrote that I'm not sure
yeah yeah you wrote that yeah it looks
like my kind of tweet what are you
trying to say no no I mean I probably
would have said the same thing oh okay
you know just maybe not the I or
something yeah I don't know maybe we're
doing like that awkward like yeah that
could be well I mean that's kind of what
he looks like here yeah yeah the smashed
face the drunk face but of course you
see the live shot of the Freedom Tower
here
um where the Twin Towers once stood so
it it and this is September 11th so I
think they're probably going to be
asking him about
oh they're gonna ask him about September
11th he's going to say something stupid
let's listen I mean I guess the best way
to describe it is it was the worst day
of my life yeah and in some ways you
know the greatest day of my life in
terms of
my city
my country my family
I mean what in the [ __ ] it was the worst
day of his life I mean I completely
understand that right yo yeah I mean it
was it was a it was the country's worst
day it's like when he says it's easy to
say that it's easy to say that September
11th even if you weren't in New York
like whoa that was one of the worst days
of our country's modern I mean I
remember where I was when the when when
the planes hit the time where were you
where were you I was going to school and
then we were everyone was at school and
then it was a lot of people I remember
that my classmates were really worried
because I had a couple friends their
their parents worked in the Sears Tower
which is now known as Wills Tower right
but they were one of the things oh we're
evacuating we're doing this so I mean
nobody had class pretty much like you
went from class to class and it was just
like uh we're not going to do anything
kind of day like it was one of those
moments where I will never forget and
I'm sure you will never forget no you
know I I well I'll tell you that um so I
I was in the midwest so there's not a
lot of tall buildings I mean you know
that's all building to us is like three
or four stories like whoa that's a big
ass building but I mean we didn't have
tall buildings so when I heard this
I was sitting in art class I remember it
um and the the kid that said it out loud
he's actually passed away now but I
remember him saying it like I remember
it exiting his mouth he said yeah they
flew those planes into those Towers now
when you're in the midwest there's
there's Towers but they're like cell
phone and radio tabs right right there's
not big tall buildings so what I thought
was like a little bitty plane flew into
one of those Towers when he said it
originally
and we started to talk about he said no
no the ones in New York the uh the the
Twin Towers
so that's when we were like whoa what
the hell and our art teacher turned it
on the radio because we didn't have a TV
in the classroom so she turned it on the
radio and like
about it wasn't much long after that
when the the plane had flew into the
Pentagon
um and we listened to that reporting
live on the air on the radio right
um and I remember that so vividly the
reason why is because the assistant
principal's office her office was very
close to the art room
and
um when that news broke you could hear
her exit her office
very fast she was very erratic and she
was screaming running down the hall were
being attacked we're being attacked
we're being gagged because
um you know the first and second tower
there's a lot of speculation but when
the Pentagon right had been hit everyone
really that was the thing that everyone
really knew yeah that wow this really is
this is real this is something really
they're attacking our country they're
not just attacking New York they're
coming after our government our way of
life and they're terrorists and they're
I mean even the people that were in New
York who were there downtown in
Manhattan didn't even know what was
going on at the time like you know
because it was so quick you know that
the first plane entered and was like
wait what what's going on you know and
then you know then later everyone seeing
the second plane and being like oh [ __ ]
okay something's going on right exactly
and it is one of those things that even
for the people that were there you know
didn't know I mean let alone us and the
Midwest the time we were like we don't
really know we don't understand I mean I
think we caught some of like the Today
Show where they covered it moments later
and they're like holy [ __ ] like what
right what's going on well because
because that day I mean um
you know it kind of continued on that
day
um you know because it wasn't just that
moment but it affected the entire
country
forever really I mean we're still paying
some of those for some of those things
then that we did you know the stuff that
we didn't know then that we do know now
we're still paying the price for some of
those things but I mean
um I I even remember I had a history
class and he was one of the only
teachers that had cable TV in his room
um lucky him but um he had the news on
and we actually watched
um one of the towers fall on live TV oh
wow which is really weird
um especially for a bunch of country
bumpkins who some of them had never even
seen that big of a building in real life
and to watch one of them fall on live TV
with some was really you know something
and we couldn't even imagine what it
would be like to be there yeah um you
know and I think
um now some of the things that we know
about the First Responders about the the
the cops the firefighters
um who were there and you hear some of
those stories and it's it's
heartbreaking so to hear Rudy Giuliani
even utter the words because I know what
he's saying here he's saying it was
great for me and my political career
right right I became America's mayor I
was the one who you know I mean like
he's also the guy that was like I never
saw Hillary Clinton down there in the
rubble and there's literally a photo
with Hillary Clinton and next with him
right they were there together right so
obviously you know he politicizes it and
and tries to use that as political like
collateral and in clout and say I was
the one who helped rebuild the city that
was attacked from something that is way
out anyways well the other thing too
that I think
you know because at the time everyone
was like oh my God Rudy giuliani's so
great right because he was the mayor and
he did you know there was this sense in
our country that This Disaster had
happened and it happened to us as
Americans and we were all together in
this the same way you would expect that
we would have came together during the
pandemic but it was the opposite right
um you know we we should have came
together and we should have said this is
a national crisis it is killing
thousands of Americans and we should all
band together to prevent this death from
happening even if our enemy is some
invisible virus and not uh you know an
ideology that has infected people's
minds right that are willing to commit
violence on us like ideology has
affecting terrorists in our country now
I mean we we watched this week as a guy
dressed in with a clown wig and a safety
vest goes into a Dairy Queen and he's
gonna kill Democrats and liberals and
make Donald Trump president King of the
United States I'm not making that [ __ ]
up yeah that is under undercover right
undercover I'm using a lot of air quotes
today but that's what they are like
right I mean they're actually used
correctly here but yeah undercover to to
bring Donald Trump back as the king and
you know I know that we joke about it
all the time but I mean like it's also
the language that they use whether it
was January 6th it was Don Jr it's any
other like marketing or ways that
they'll send you emails or texts and
it's like hey make sure to donate to the
Maga King Donald Trump you say it enough
times and people believe you that's the
way that this person should be referred
to so like you've got a crazy guy and
clown that go clown you know uh costume
or mask that goes into a Dairy Queen a
[ __ ] Dairy Queen like where you'd go
get a blizzard right and he goes in
there with guns and you know tries to
like of all places Dairy Queen's gonna
play be the place that he's gonna
reinstate Trump that is the insanity I
don't think it's supposed to make sense
just like it doesn't make sense to fly
planes in the buildings right right and
a lot of people are going to say oh Tony
and Gabe you're being [ __ ] comparing
those terrorists to Maga supporters
um I don't think it's too far of a
stretch folks yeah I don't think it's
too far of a stretch when when you watch
that they're believing in right-wing
ideology and not only are they believing
in it the delusion of it but they're
acting it out in violent ways like an
Insurrection like going to an FBI
headquarters with a staple gun and a
firearm like going the Dairy Queen with
a firearm and these these instances keep
happening they keep threatening online
and you have the actual leaders the
politicians making tapes of themselves
saying this stuff it sounds familiar it
sounds like um what's that group that
flew planes into buildings I'm just
saying that that it is the same it
doesn't matter if if you're if it's a
different religion if it's a different
country and you're a different race it
doesn't matter it's the same [ __ ] it's
the same [ __ ] and we should be vigilant
and [ __ ] Rudy Giuliani to be quite
honest he can [ __ ] all the way off I
mean that was I mean him saying that was
incredibly disgusting and so so uncalled
for because like you know then you got
to think
how do the families feel right all of
the people that experience Trauma from
the from those that they lost or
survivors that have trauma and PTSD the
people or even the First Responders his
comment is so uh
so gross and disgusting and violent it's
good for me politically it made me who I
am today you're a piece of [ __ ] you can
you can feel that Rudy you're not
supposed to say that quiet part out loud
dummy speaking of people who say the
quiet part out loud
holy [ __ ] Mike Lindell cannot shut the
[ __ ] up Gabe oh boy he cannot shut up
um um
so we know now that he was
he was stopped at a Hardee's
drive-through yeah he was getting
whatever Burger
you know this is the question I've got
this question from people they're like
well is it the same cell phone that he
had two years ago that doesn't make
sense I'm like look you know when you go
get an iPhone and you buy a new iPhone
you know the procedure you do a backup
on the old phone and you download that
to the new phone just like you did the
last three times so all the last three
cell phones are all now on that phone
that is how it works yeah this that is
how it works I mean the only difference
is they're just Milestones of like all
right here's all the terrible things
that I did or said here here's all the
crimes I come in on my iPhone nine yeah
and then there was the 10 and the 11 and
each part it shows you phase by phase of
how I was a a traitorous uh terrible
human on which iPhone yeah yeah
right
through through his different he became
a better treasonous pieces [ __ ] as the
phones got better it is true they were
better at at plotting a coup as they got
newer editions of the iPhone but that's
what my first thought was is of course
it's the old iPhone because that's the
first thing you do I mean literally Mike
Lindell would have to Chuck his old
iPhone into the ocean and then and then
go get a brand new iPhone and start from
scratch but he couldn't do that Gabe
because he's running like 35 000
businesses right that's what he says
that's what he that's what he said last
night
doesn't make a lot of sense though when
you I mean when you begin to fact check
and say hey is there any truth to what
you're saying I mean look I can only
trust Mike Lindell as far as or or as
comfortable as his pillows are which
obviously as anyone knows are [ __ ]
[ __ ] so they're not very they're not
very comfortable so I don't trust the
guy right
but when he was talking last night he
started saying some things I was like oh
wait I remember that name or oh wait I
remember that sounds familiar right and
he started talking about Tina Peters and
some other people that were on this
document as other [ __ ]
co-conspirators right
well I've got I've got video evidence
here that he's got more than one phone
oh yeah this is this is the best to date
this is the best Mike Lindell content
that exists anywhere on the Internet is
this video right here uh for all of you
who don't know which if you haven't seen
this where the hell have you been
sleeping underneath the Mind fellow
um this is uh we figured out this is in
a courtyard in San Diego right yeah
that's a hotel that's what I that's what
people commented on the video when I
shared it okay so if you look here this
right here this little this Feller here
who um
looks like Mike Lindell how does he so
recognizable even from the back
he just has that like a blockhead you
know is that what it is I just feel like
he just has that you don't need to see
him from the front to just know that's
that's Lindell Vibes right here right
right it really does look like he even
sleeps on one of his shitty pillows uh
just by his posture and stuff on the
chair but you can see here he's got a
phone that he's talking into but on the
table Gabe there's another phone there
right so that guy's got that too so he
doesn't have one he's got one and
another one right he's got two in this
video at least so this I mean this is
simple math anyone can do this math and
follow along one well one I mean besides
people who can't count votes and I know
yeah well you know but let's watch
because there's a surprise in this video
for people who haven't seen it now
everyone who has seen it you're not
gonna you're not gonna be sad because
this is the greatest content that the
internet can possibly produce here so we
could watch this every single day and
still love this video
Patriots
no oh I'm sorry about that so he's live
on TV right yeah so he's talking live
just like we do why would you not do
this you're in the you're in a hotel
Courtyard why would you not do this in
your actual room
well I mean it depends on what the
room's like and what you did the night
before in there I mean you know okay who
knows who knows what that what the
condition of Mike lindell's room is but
of all places I mean a public Courtyard
it's already noisy enough I mean I get
that he's got the airpods in but like
come on man come on you really think
that this mustache Mussolini has any
kind of brain to realize that he
probably shouldn't do it in a public but
Gabe there's something else about this
video yeah it's not just in a public
Courtyard now he is in a public
Courtyard
but watch this watch this fight man keep
fighting don't don't let the lip tarps
kill your names
um Gabe does he have pants on
it looks like he's either wearing shorts
or underwear those are boxers the dude
the dude didn't even put pants on the go
in the corner this is a typical routine
that you would find uh working from home
right during the pandemic and when
you're in quarantine you have meetings
boom business
gate does not wear pants on the show I
don't wear pants right now I got a shirt
and I'm just nothing underneath you know
so but I mean for those watching we're
not in a quick abnormal right they are
not the difference do that in the
privacy of my own home I will not do
that onto others in a public Courtyard
at a hotel you're saying you won't do a
tubing on the on the uh on the tubes no
no tubing no moving definitely not in
public and no lindellen in the courtyard
now there's more there's more than just
this tape because he got his phone
seized which one am I looking at here
for the uh I think it's the second one
here is that is where where he went on
what is it called Lindell TV what is
this I can't figure out what the [ __ ] is
Lindell TV okay Lindell TV is the TV
network so that's not the show nope nope
nope not the show and then he's got the
Lindell report now that is a show okay
so it's Frank's Speech TV Lindell TV
well no no no yeah
Lindell TV the Lindell report so you
just gotta come down a little bit so
where do you where do you watch this
garbage because you watched it so we
don't have to right yeah yeah you can
watch it at franksbeach.com so you're
welcome no don't don't go whatever you
do don't go you probably would be able
to find this stuff on rumble.com as well
but the main source of this content is
on frankspeach.com well here's the thing
you can just go subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast on Twitter on YouTube
tube stay tuned there we will try to
bring you the relevant crazy ass Mike
Lindell clips that way you don't have to
watch it
um but here is now this is a little
different clip than what most people are
watching this is one you posted on
Twitter but I think because this is him
this is him starting the story off this
is like oh yeah we're driving through
Iowa coming back home or whatever I was
hunting and this is when he gets to the
whole like
how he was or where he was confronted
when they found out that he was criming
well they didn't find out they just went
to get the evidence because that's the
real thing here that that these [ __ ]
aren't really talking about is they're
like he can't take a cell phone it's
illegal that no it's not not when they
have probable cause what are you talking
about if they have a problem based on
the evidence they have to say hey look
crimes were committed it's the same
[ __ ] that people say oh president
Trump's home in Mar-A-Lago shouldn't
have been rated well it turns out that a
federal judge said oh yeah this actually
does make sense and you should act on it
right now so I will
sign off on this warrant and that's what
people need to realize you know what I'm
just thinking this so if if the FBI can
go and they have probable cause that you
committed crime on your cell phone and
they can have probable cause to go get
it rather you're convicted and died in a
convicted or not as long as they have
probable cause to get it then get it
don't you think they could do that same
thing with documents maybe even if
they're your documents yeah I mean he
probably he doesn't own them but if you
did what hypothetically say you own
documents like you owned a cell phone
and you committed crime with those
documents couldn't you go get those back
even though you're yeah I'm just saying
I'm just saying let's listen to
um the My Pillow Nazi mustache Mussolini
talk about how they took his cell phone
and we go through a Hardee's drive
through
around the back and we're just about
going through we pulled through the
drive-through to take the order everyone
knows how a drive-through works I don't
know actually up until this point I
didn't know how Drive they worked but
thank you Mike Lindell I mean he
literally he literally is telling us how
if I could drive through Works in this
story like yeah everyone everyone pretty
much knows how a [ __ ] drive-through
Works Mike what are you talking about
why are you explaining this isn't 1940.
in case you didn't know right this is so
there's a there's a line that's painted
it goes around the building there's some
doors that you can walk through but
there's these main two windows typically
that you'll go and talk any window yeah
and a food window see and the other
thing too is they got to be on a certain
side of the building right so that way
you the driver because you're on you're
obviously let me explain how how we
drive on a certain side of the Jesus
Christ this guy let's listen
we pull up and she says pull ahead you
know because they had to make the order
it's harder it wasn't done yeah no [ __ ]
go ahead
and a car comes perpendicular and Parks
like a little ways in front of us and I
and I've been around the block and I
said to my he's been around the block so
much he knows how a drive through works
I was gonna say yeah he he's been around
the block that has the drive-through
he's been around the drive-through he
knows how this works he puts the order
in she had to go away and put up the
order and then we moved forward this is
the kind of content you expect from
Lindell TV explaining how the
drive-through works okay so so he's in
the drive-through yeah that's what he
could have said yeah I was in in the
drive drive
and the car cuts in front of me now
we're at that part of the story Jesus
Mike stop doing crack crack is bad crack
is whack funny I said
um that's either a bad guy or it's it's
FBI
okay so it's either a it's either a bad
guy game or a good guy yeah is that what
he's saying I mean is there any other
there's I mean there there is no other
it's either the person who wants to
commit some crime because maybe I did
something maybe I owe my dealer money
who knows right or it's the people that
are you know uh supporting Justice and
democracy the good guys the ones who are
fighting to make sure that people don't
break the rules or the laws or try to I
don't know invalidate an election and
overthrow government just thinking just
cooing a little yeah I don't know just
small I don't know small little coup
yeah oh my God I I said that straight up
and we go through a Hardee's
drive-through straight up man straight
up he said it straight up and he was
like and I told him it's like that
person that tells you a joke and you're
like hey it was it's this is so funny
this is such a funny joke and then
they're like oh you just had to be there
you know and you're like uh uh I don't
know if it's that fun if you have to
tell me it's a funny joke before you
tell me the joke that it might not be so
funny right right well so he had his
phone sees but Gabe there's more there's
a lot deeper stuff to this story yes
because of why he got his phone he's
probably the most important part because
this spans back not just to the coup on
January 6. this wraps all the way up to
last year and we've made fun of it
several times the size cyber Symposium I
think there's a few important things
here number one who financed this cyber
Symposium yeah supposedly supposedly
Lindell had put in at the time 15
million dollars
for that piece of [ __ ] yeah did you
watch some of that I mean we're gonna
watch it yeah yeah I remember watching
that day yeah I don't know dude I don't
know where he's getting this money but
he throws it around a little money is
this right like he probably I mean we
need stuffed in the pillows but I gotta
imagine it's got to be pillow money what
are we doing sitting here talking to
micros we need to start a pillow company
this is crazy this is crazy well
he gives a cyber Symposium but there's a
lady who shows up there and this is
really I think why they've taken this
cell phone and because man this gets
really thick and the reason why it gets
really thick is because not only was
Mike Lindell there and spearheading that
Steve Bannon was at the Cyber Symposium
he spoke there he was there the whole
time he was pushing it on his show and
all his [ __ ] how it was gonna you know
Crown Donald Trump president King of the
United States whatever the hell that
clown thought but here is a clip
um and I think this is super important
because this person is currently
indicted
for for crimes of which Mike Lindell has
accused Democrats of doing am I wrong
there and saying I mean around my pretty
spot on you're pretty spot on with the
irony yeah so this is her name is Tina
Peters you're gonna hear this name in
the next few months a lot yeah where
you're gonna see my pillow and Tina
Peters you're gonna see those two words
connected like the keywords on the
internet those two things are really
gonna you know kind of [ __ ] have a
baby I think
um but Tina Peters here she was at the
Cyber Symposium was she not gay this is
where this is yeah this was August of
2021 she was a speaker or at one of the
panels they're basically just sitting at
a table that's what it is it's a mind
you just to set the stage if you will uh
they're on they're on they're on stage
and they have this like long kind of
like foldable table that's there and
they've got a big screen behind the 15
million dollar one yeah yeah a lot of
technical difficulties they made a movie
that was like 15 or a movie that was 15
minutes and they played that over and
over over and over again because they
failed to show any sort of proof that
there was fraud but you mean there's no
evidence yeah there's no I'm sorry I'm
sorry to bust I'm sorry to ruin it for
you man there's no evidence but in in
this Auditorium or whatever it was there
were a bunch of tables uh with very
spotty people like it was not very it
was it wasn't very filled at all right
and as as it went on as they played this
15 minutes over and over and over again
again yeah and not only that
but they did not really feed anyone they
didn't provide meals I think they had
someone complimentary like continental
breakfast type snacks or whatever mints
yeah but they're like we wasted we spent
all our money on this 15 minute video
that we're gonna play again and again
and again
on a table and a video that's what they
Jesus I don't know I mean ripoff the the
irony of having a cyber Symposium but
also not knowing how to work computers
at said cyber symposium
is um when you're supposed to be
collecting evidence or whatever they
were doing when you're like oh we got
all this fraud now Tina Peter's here she
doesn't know how to work computers she
even had to steal
allegedly steal a badge to and and to
get some information off a voting
machine she actually tampered which is
what they accuse everyone else of doing
they actually intentionally tampered
with voting machines she's one of them
um and she well let's just watch this
and we'll talk about it just yesterday I
got an order from the secretary of state
that she was going to invade my
elections Department today and guess
what when I was on a plane to come see
you kind folks and to talk to you out
there guess what they did they provided
a search warrant and raided my office oh
this sounds familiar oh I I love the
invade word yeah they invaded they
raided also they gave you a [ __ ]
heads up right they told you we're
coming we're coming to win I what why
the word invade you know I I get they
wanna they wanna say raid like I get
that like I'm not against saying you
know some people are like don't call it
a raid that's just playing into the
right wing like and it's a [ __ ] raid
yeah like go look up the [ __ ]
definition yeah serving a search warrant
a rating ants come on come on you're
you're picking you're picking it picky
[ __ ] but invade like you're like you're
invading a country on the beaches or
something I don't know yeah it's not
yeah doesn't she look like the Karen
that would yell and scream because she
got two less slices of of hammock yeah
I'm pretty sure that she would be
someone that would totally throw a bunch
of racist [ __ ] and throws him oh well
there's actually more to it but we'll
keep going but okay there's actually
more to that type of reaction okay let's
let's play
we don't know what they were doing in
there because for several hours they
wouldn't even let my chief Deputy clerk
who is the acting clerk from Mesa County
when I'm absent would not even let her
observe what the Secretary of State and
Dominion were doing in my office alone
for several hours in the voting room
alone who is the lady who is narrating
I don't I don't know that's our job okay
lady don't interrupt my video don't I
like how she also goes we don't know
what they were there for yes we do yeah
we do why they were there you schemed to
commit election fraud you stole because
what what is what is the story because
they're not going to tell us here
exactly what they did the time that they
committed so what is allegedly the crime
so the story goes like this and uh it's
a it's a bitching story let me tell you
yeah so if we go back just a step here
the search warrant that Mike Lindell got
served at Hardee's it's a probe okay say
that again say that again say that again
the search warrant that Mike Lindell got
served in a Hardee's drive-through let
me be more specific about it that is
fantastic that's great comedy that's
right it's because they wanted the
contents of his phone as they were part
of a larger investigation into a
Colorado election security breach now
Tina Peters is a county clerk Mesa
County Clerk from Colorado now in in the
warrant uh the probe is looking into
conduct involving Tina Peters Conan
James Hayes Belinda nicely Sandra Brown
Sharona Bishop Mike Lindell and or
Douglas Frank among other
co-conspirators known or unknown to the
government
the reason they're looking into this is
because Tina Peters and the rest of the
stop the steel people
orchestrate or I guess allegedly
orchestrated a plan that involved Conan
James Hayes pretending to be this I.T
Tech worker in order to copy the Mesa
County voting machine software you were
saying you're saying that they they they
lied about someone being someone else
they went in and they tampered with
these machines in order to get a copy to
give to who but it's not only that Tina
Peters is the person who stole the uh
the local I.T Consultants badge whoa
whoa whoa so you're saying not only did
they pose as someone but they didn't
just happen upon this badge like they
you know they actually stole it I mean
they stole they stole it it was I
believe the charges also are stolen
identity and impersonating someone is
amongst the she's got like 10 criminal
charges three misdemeanors and seven
felonies does this not sound good for
Tina yes here so that that is that is
why well I mean like you said you're
going to hear more and more of her name
over the next few months because this
thing is [ __ ] bananas right right
well let's let's see what she else she
they claim here let's see if the
narrator kicks in here again
alone with no one that knew anything
about elections watching what they did
but they did do this do you is she
saying the Secretary of State doesn't
know anything about elections isn't the
Secretary of State the like the head but
also if you're if you if you have the
FBI searching your office for Stuff
invading invading if you have the FBI
invading your office because you
committed a crime
I'm pretty sure they're going to send
the right people in that know they don't
need to know anything about elections
they need to know if they're coming in
to grab any computers like tech people
uh they're going to be dusting for
fingerprints they're looking for
specific documents right because these
the things that were stolen from the
Dominion voting machine were then spread
online
which found its way to the Cyber
Symposium via Mike Lindell oh wait a
second so you're saying that the
information that the person who is
sitting on stage right here in this
cyber Symposium the information that she
stole they they kind of in some way or
fashion brought it to this thing yep and
they actually in public committed crime
are you kidding me do you really think
that Maga Republicans at trumpladites
that these America First Nazis would do
such a thing Gabe this is quite an
accusation so of stupidity and
bone-headed already here that you're of
all those names that I listed that were
in there as co-conspirators the the
connection there if we connect to
different the Dots here so also it
should come it's no surprise that the
guy that pretended to be the the tech
right the the the tech worker the Conan
James Hayes he's a conspiracy theorist
whoa and also has ties to Mike Lindell
oh Douglas Frank who is also listed in
this system where he gets the the
Frank's speech you know I thought about
it I I don't know I thought about that
when I was when I was kind of doing the
research on this but Douglas Frank
reportedly passed along that information
about the scheme to Lindell who was
already spreading election lies about
Dominion voting machines so now you tie
in the guy the woman who planned it
Italian the guy who pretended to be the
tech worker you tie in the guy who
passed off the information and then you
tie in Michael and Dell who's holding
the Cyber Symposium and already is going
you know as a batshit crazy conspiracy
theorist to say that the election was
rigged now you're tying all these people
together and I wouldn't be surprised if
a lot of those Communications were on a
cell phone that was seized
well you know the other thing too is it
sounds like uh having a shitty uh setup
here and not preparing food and having
you know a great Symposium as opposed to
the shits and supposing that through
them for 50 million seems like 15
million was spread somewhere else
possibly let's listen to the end of this
video
I don't know what they did I don't know
what they did but I can tell you that I
don't trust them
oh boy this sounds very familiar it
sounds very familiar it does and it was
a year earlier
this this type of way you're saying are
you saying there's a pattern here it's
almost like when somebody like the FBI
conducts a search of a of a a place a
home or an office they remove a person
who might be I don't know a conflict of
interest who might also have inside
knowledge who might want to I don't know
disrupt the flow and take something when
someone's not looking because I mean
they're not gonna let the criminals
stand in the room while they're trying
to find the crime that they committed
this is ridiculous this is ridiculous
they should always raid someone at a
Hardee's I'm just saying this should be
a new law that we should pass it only
happens
and maybe an Arby's maybe maybe an
Arby's maybe we got was there what is it
we got the meat we got the meat the
music the meat
um so this video here is from the Cyber
Symposium too I'm gonna play it real
quick and then we'll talk about it on
the other side
oh we have a problem
my lawyer my lawyer just called me Ty
Clevenger Mr Ty Clevenger
and he said
uh that I should put out the statement
and I just learned that Conan James
Hayes may have taken without
authorization
the actual hard drives from the Mesa
County or the Mesa
Colorado county clerk
and he needs to produce those hard
drives immediately and return them to
the clerk
and we should stop this data review
until he produces the hard drives this
guy looks familiar game who is this this
guy looks for me it's almost like he ran
for congress somewhere who is this guy
yeah yeah uh in Arizona oh really yeah
you know he looks like he looks like one
of these Q Anon nuts onto something here
he does he he does look like someone who
might run a site that would promote uh
propaganda who is this who is this
mysterious person who won't continue
because his lawyer said hey dude you're
going to be a part of crime you're going
to be federally investigated you're
gonna be federally dead that is what is
interesting so what we have here for
those who don't know the guy that was on
the screen that we were showing is Ron
Watkins okay Q Anon man not VQ but he's
a q Anon supporter he spreads their
property
right right and so the big thing here is
he's not listed or at least at least at
least not on this document is not listed
as a
co-conspiratory right and I don't know
if he either is aiding in the
investigation or he backed out before
[ __ ] hit the fan
because obviously he's backing out here
and and very publicly during the point
where he because he was there to to
analyze this data forever which he also
did there's another clip of him going
through the data and then being like Oh
you just happen to be having technical
difficulties whenever you need to
present the data like he just calls them
out during which was a hilarious moment
I can pull the clip for you but in that
moment Ron Watkins basically just calls
him out for being like you guys don't
have the data and every time people ask
for it you just say oh we're gonna go to
the commercial or you have a problem but
because the data they stole is the data
that was produced in the election
results
right so so now I mean there's obviously
more underlying data but the ultimate
idea that someone tampered with the
original data and messed with the count
the vote count is ridiculous and they
know it's ridiculous because they have
the data they stole it they stole the
data that proves that so that was
correct do you want to know why they
knew to raid uh or invade Tina Peter's
office tell me it's because of Ron
Watkins so Ron Watkins helped spread
this [ __ ] all over a Chan and whatnot in
other places but here's the thing these
documents have passwords and other names
and they all [ __ ] Trace back to Tina
Peter's office oh Jesus
so that is why they knew hey we should
go look into this because her digital
fingerprint is all over this [ __ ] well
so he spread it she got busted mind you
this don't happen to the Cyber Symposium
so this [ __ ] is blowing up in real time
and so uh the other video that I I sent
you really quick is him calling this out
in real time being like this is just you
guys don't have anything organized this
[ __ ] is a [ __ ] show
let's watch a bit of this and then we'll
we gotta move on to the other bonus I
love this Mike Lindell you could do like
a bonehead of like the whole week you
could just do
mm-hmm I mean we can just make this
channel Mike Lindell content and we
would be okay we would be certainly okay
and we would we would have plenty of
content to uh go through but let's watch
Ron Watkins here at the Cyber Symposium
tell them they're full of [ __ ]
yeah
it's quite coincidental that the video
feed breaks and the live streaming
platforms break as soon as we start
talking about this
so
what's what's funny is when this was all
happening people were like live
streaming like on Tic Tac and [ __ ] and
saying this is all nonsense like even
the people who believed it like this is
all [ __ ] yeah this is why Mike
Lindell has never really caught on he's
never really caught on his because he
yeah I mean he's more full of [ __ ] than
the Trump family I mean it is ridiculous
how much but this guy had the you know
had the ear of trump as well as he was
at the White House do you remember that
with his papers and not only in his
phone he had his phone I mean he was I
mean they were all talking about martial
law you know then you got the
overstock.com CEO or the homie what is
with these [ __ ] weird things what the
hell is with it well let's let's move on
because those are our our non-winners so
that kind of gives it away but I want to
move on to the dishonorable mention here
um this [ __ ] guy yeah this is the guy
you're saying he's totally hateable I
think Alan Franken says I like Ted Cruz
more than um most of my colleagues and
my colleagues hate take care is that
what he says what what is he I think
that's I think that's how it goes yeah
yeah it's close to that yeah yeah well
that's close enough right
basically moral the story is Everybody
Hates [ __ ] Ted Cruz who doesn't who
doesn't uh hate take groups yeah like I
said earlier so to his daughter's thing
they've made a tick tock about their
life under his
you know uh so let's see what's the uh
oh this is the tweet that I want
um so he the one reason why he's on bone
of the week is because of um some of the
school shootings and you've all are in
in Texas specifically Uvaldi
um Kimberly posted here where this this
family is sharing uh a photo of their
child
in a casket with him that's what that's
the phone a child size casket right that
that Ted Cruz is holding there and of
course he looks like you could hate the
[ __ ] right um just I like I hate
him I mean the attitude that I get from
him is like
and you're showing me this because right
like that's the vibe I get from his like
the the lack of like hey like these
parents if you look at body language
like I know of you know very basic body
language but these people are coming in
to try to they're like yeah they're
listening in
and she's consoling him on the back
because obviously this is a very
traumatic and and sad story or or
experience that they're trying to get
him to understand
and he's laid back and he's like
yeah so she's in a casket whatever which
is the [ __ ] terrible like
yeah
he's such a [ __ ] scumbag this is
almost as scummy as [ __ ] while it's
just as scummy I mean the same kind of
scum is Rudy Giuliani right saying
saying oh the uh 911 was the best day of
my life my Jesus [ __ ] people but
there's something else he did he went on
a floor
of the Senate here's a video of this son
of a [ __ ] after he did that here's the
son of a [ __ ] oh you like the face
leather here
maybe that's all I should show let's
just wish.com wannabe Wolverine we're
gonna watch a bit of this because
there's actually another version in this
video that I want to show that I think
is more appropriate but let's watch this
version from C-SPAN too the Uvalde
shooting was the deadliest school
shooting
in Texas history
before that
I was in Santa Fe
or yet another evil madman okay I can't
I can't take it I can't take it because
honestly he's doing the thing where he's
like oh I went and I spent time with
these families but then when it came
time to vote on a bill that would
protect children not just in Texas but
all around the country from [ __ ]
people with weapons of war going in and
tearing them apart yeah
I mean it the because we both watched
this video and it's not very long but he
goes through dramatic pause after
dramatic pause after dramatic pause and
saying it was uh you vality it was uh
you know El Paso it was here it was here
it was here and he goes through
and in a similar fashion to Sean Hannity
listing out all of the crimes that Trump
has been investigated for
he goes through a list of places just in
[ __ ] Texas
where people have used guns to kill
other people in a mass shooting children
up to adults right and and Ted Cruz used
to this moment to somehow believe that
what he's saying actually makes an
argument for we need to protect these
children more by bringing more guns in
more gun more guns that's the answer
if you list out all of these travesties
that happen
you're like uh maybe the problem is the
[ __ ] guns right well someone redid
this video one of our friends here
Holly teaks ticks and um I think it's
more appropriate Senator count chocolate
because he's Counting how many it's
[ __ ] gross but let's well this is a
much better version let's watch yeah the
Uvalde shooting was the deadliest school
shooting
in Texas history
before that
I was in Santa Fe
or yet another evil Madman
killed eight students and two teachers
so he's counting the school shootings in
Texas that he refuses to do anything
right to stop because he believes the
problem is he doesn't believe not [ __ ]
he's not a principal [ __ ] he's
just like the rest of these Republicans
they don't believe [ __ ] it's all about
their con it's all it's not about the
constituents it's about the goddamn
manufacturers about the goddamn NRA
putting money in their [ __ ] Pockets
winning them goddamn elections [ __ ] [ __ ]
these Maga Republicans [ __ ] them and I'm
sick and tired and boy this you've all
this [ __ ] really gets me going because I
got school-aged children just like a lot
of people out there and we're sick and
tired of [ __ ] people gaslighting us
telling us the only way to keep our
[ __ ] kids safe in schools is to build
big fences put locks on the doors and
have more guns and we know that's all
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's all [ __ ] do
your [ __ ] job and do the job of
government and regulate these things to
keep these [ __ ] kids safe and oh by
the way [ __ ] Ted Cruz exactly [ __ ] Ted
Cruz okay let's move on to the alpha
here here almost is hateable almost
almost almost
oh my God an asset here is almost as
hate about this guy no Rand Paul who
just another person who uh who supports
the Insurrection you know you know the
nice part about
um Rand Paul is that you can hate him
but for some odd reason some odd reason
you love his neighbor and you don't even
know his neighbor and you love it I
don't know the neighbors I don't know
the neighbor's name I don't know where
he lives exactly but I will say that
there's a lot of people
based on what Rand Paul does or rather
lack thereof when it comes to
constituents that people will be like
yeah I like that guy I would move it
actually that [ __ ] guy you know if
you had one wish to grant our Genie had
one wish for you I don't know maybe you
would warrant
to be Rand Paul's neighbor that would be
the one wish that you would you would
wish for now this is this is in a uh a
senate meeting of course fauci's here uh
Rand Paul's Arch Enemy Dr fauci
um and the best actual and actual doctor
right an actual doctor give me one not
Rand Paul right not one that made up a
certificate and tried to pass it off
I've made up certificate a certificate
he believes I don't know did he print it
off a printer and then I mean not to
take it back to Michael Lindell but if
you look if you go if anyone watches
goes back to when we're showing clips of
Michael and devil over his shoulder he's
got a certificate of excellence for
Michael J Lindell who gave it to him
probably him and he probably printed off
online or got it from Trump University I
don't [ __ ] know I'm definitely gonna
get one of those I need one of those a
certificate of excellence right back
here you got to get it for Michael J
Lindell not for Tony yeah well no
absolutely it's got to be for him who
else would print their own [ __ ]
certificate of excellence maybe Rand
Paul let's watch she said the flu for 14
days should she get a flu shot well no
if she got the flu for 14 days she's as
protected as anybody can be because the
best vaccination is to get infected
yourself and so if she really has the
flu if she really has the flu she
definitely doesn't need a flu vaccine
if she really has the floats she should
not get it again no she doesn't need it
because it's the it's the most potent
vaccination is getting infected yourself
okay so this is a video that Anthony
fauci did on C-Span years ago he was
asked a question on the show he
responded to the question on the show he
actually the the answer that he gives is
not is not opposite of what he says now
it's actually the exact same thing then
he says now they just try to use this to
twist this like in Threads and [ __ ] and
they try to get you all uh you know
discombobulated which is what Rand Paul
tries to do here he's unsuccessful
um with Anthony bounce you watch this
as you can see on my iPad I [ __ ] got
you dude got you [ __ ] because really
honestly if rainfall really thought he
would get Anthony found you with this
[ __ ] clip he'd have done this a long
time ago but he's running at it he's
running out of sticks here he's got to
go all the way to the shitty internet to
get these to get these tactics let's
watch it's an ongoing question and you
know we've had ever evolving opinions
from you Dr fauci currently Annabelle
that's because that's how never mind
yeah you wouldn't you wouldn't know what
the word science and medical science
means so I'm gonna you know go over
there virus or you know [ __ ] idiot
mutations from that virus what a dumbass
body surveys show that uh 80 of children
approximately 80 percent of children
have had covid and yet there are no
guidelines coming from you or anybody in
the government to take into account
their naturally acquired immunity you
seem quite certain of yourself in 2004
but in 2022 there's a lot less certainty
team one of the things that we also know
again I want to point something out here
I want to point something out the reason
why Dr fauci has more certainty about
the [ __ ] flu in 2004 is because the
flu was a couple years old by then yeah
like this idea that we didn't know that
Dr fauci wouldn't know a [ __ ] ton of
[ __ ] information and Science and
medical and you know there's tons of
medical studies on the flu influenza
then covid or even monkeys which is also
you know and for people yeah it's like
you know we've had influenza for years
now and the reason that it's not as
deadly as say I don't know a novel virus
called covid-19 is because it's not a
[ __ ] novel virus it's not the first
strain of it that's protecting people
that nobody or the second third or
fourth right exactly it's been around
for a hundred years or more been around
for a while it is it is a lessened
version yes it can kill people and yes
it can be very sickening or deadly to
people but that is years years of it
going through different strains and
mutations and you know knowing more
about I mean we're even in a situation
now where I think most people feel
comfortable
um with covet at this point I mean you
well we have to be you know right well I
mean you get vaccine I mean we're gonna
live with it like we live with the flu
right so that's just what we're going to
do that's called I don't know
science it we're not going to be able to
get rid of these things I mean hopefully
someday there may be technology that
allows us to do that but at this point
in history we do not have the capability
to eradicate things like the flu or
covet but Rand Paul seems to not
understand anything so I know he's not a
doctor so you wouldn't get it he's a
[ __ ] and he wouldn't he's not a doctor
who actually studies
infectious diseases who is who is is it
the guy that he's questioning let's see
after looking at this for two to three
years uh is that the mortality uh from
covet is very similar if not less than
than influenza nope not even so when we
look at this we wonder
you know why you seem to really you know
I don't wonder at all technology back in
2004 and how you or why you seem to
reject it now because it's two different
things well I don't reject basic
Immunology Senator and I have never
denied that there is importance of the
protection
following infection
however as we have said many times and
as has been validated by the
authorization
of the by the FDA through their
committee and the recommendation
by the CDC through their committee
that a vaccination following infection
gives an added extra boost and that film
that you showed is really taken out of
context I believe that was when someone
called in who had had a reaction to a
vaccine and asked me through a telephone
in the interview if they should get
vaccinated again so it was in the
context of someone who had a reaction
so in other words she got the flu from
getting the vaccine and she wanted to
know if she should go get another
vaccine and he's saying in the clip no
you've already got the flu wait wait
wait wait wait so you mean
that a republican took a clip
and took it out of context
without adding the phone call the
question the person who it was about the
specific situation what I'm what I'm
saying here is this guy that you see on
the screen here yeah yeah he's a vile
piece of [ __ ] oh yeah he knows what he's
doing I actually don't think Rand Paul's
stupid I actually don't think Rand Paul
which makes this worse right exactly he
he knows he knows the basics here and
this video really shows it and and fauci
dunks him in the [ __ ] garbage
here let's watch the you did cry and
people decry vaccine hesitancy it's
coming from the gobbledygook that you
give us you're not paying attention to
the sides the very basic science is that
previous infection provides a level of
immunity if you ignore that in your
studies if you don't present that in
your committees you're not being
truthful or honest with US senator if I
might respond I have never ever denied
fundamental Immunology in fact I wrote
the chapter in the textbook of medicine
any of the guidelines for vaccines you
know he wrote the [ __ ] book
yeah he's like look yeah I get that you
may have read the Wikipedia on this but
I [ __ ] wrote it right I [ __ ] wrote
the actual textbook that people learn
from in medical school not that you
would have learned this in your
non-medical school degree
but listen up bucko like the idea that
it's always Rand Paul versus like Dr
fauci's like look dude I'm just trying
to save lives and you're over here
trying to make my job harder like I'm
trying to retire and you're trying to
pull me back into the [ __ ] game of
this hey you said this you did this and
fauci's like I didn't say that you took
it out of context I didn't do that and
again this was before a flu that already
existed
not one that was already had a deadly
virus that was attacking the world the
[ __ ] world a pandemic and the reason
we had a shutdown was because or the
reason that they said yeah you should
get the vaccine because we had no
protection we had no immunity it was
just going up against this thing without
any Shield any armor
well now I want to go to
speaking of
pieces of garbage because boy you guys
voted overwhelmingly yeah holy [ __ ] it
was like a [ __ ] it was a blue gate
out of the gate I really thought Mike
Lindell had a chance
but after what Lindsey Graham said and
how he put it now we have some other
video footage here because
um we have Lindsey Graham's original
statement and and uh I'm just gonna play
a bit of that and then we also have
um his response I think on Jesse Warner
show but then he's got um a video
also
um somewhere else so let's watch this
one here this is the press conference
that he gave and Gabe he's talking about
a national ban on abortion now
Republicans are in big trouble here
politically because Americans are on to
them because they want to take people's
freedom away from them yeah but listen
to what listen to what the bone end of
the week says here in this in this
little clip so we're gonna have an
election in 2022
if we take back the house and the Senate
I can assure you we'll have a vote on
our bill
if the Democrats are in charge I don't
know if we'll ever have a vote on our
bill so what are you saying what he's
saying is you got a choice America you
can vote for republicans and they'll
take away your freedoms or you can vote
for Democrats and they'll actually
codify your freedoms those are your
choices so what do you want you like you
like your rights right you don't like
your rights right right right right well
I mean this is pretty easy stuff this is
why which again like the [ __ ] you
know we've got we've got I think it's
Blake Masters and some other people that
have taken off their abortions from
their website because they've seen they
thought this leak was going to help them
they thought this leak and then the
decision from the Supreme Court was
going to show hey you know what we're
doing what the people wanted oh surprise
surprise turns out that a very few do
not represent the majority of people who
said get the [ __ ] out of my body
right well they Americans in general I
don't care if you're Republican Democrat
independent Christian not whatever the
[ __ ] you are out there if you're in this
country you value your freedom and and
you value the ability for people not to
tell you what the [ __ ] to do especially
someone who looks like Lindsey Graham
but uh Jamie Raskin hey he goes he takes
to the house floor and he burns Lindsey
Graham's house down
um watch what this is a fantastic piece
of footage watch Jamie Raskin take
Lindsey Graham out behind the Woodshed
and spank his little ass here yesterday
Senator Lindsey Graham introduced
legislation for a national criminal ban
on abortion but of course the the
so-called pro-life forces want to go
further in the states uh and ban it
completely a lot of them don't even want
to allow exceptions for rape or incest I
thought our colleagues were going to
explain what their position really is I
would invite them to do so as long as
they don't want to talk about the
legislation before us today why don't
they tell us what their position on
abortion is because America wants to
know I think their position uh has
changed somewhat they're singing a
somewhat different tune since the people
of Kansas by 20 points destroyed their
anti-choice agenda and explained to them
in numerical terms that the people of
America are on the side of freedom
so there's Jamie raske and you know the
best Jamie you're asking do you know the
best Jamie you're asking is Jamie this
Jamie you're asking dark dark Jamie
Raskin baby we should I don't know maybe
we should clip it I don't know but he
brings up a great point right he says
that they were totally fine with it and
then we saw what happened in Kansas and
when the white Master's another like and
when Republicans also learned that oh
actually maybe people don't want us to
take away these rights or rather they
didn't like the fact that we uh we took
away Roe v Wade and we haven't codified
it it's
the thing that is very telling here is
that they now said well okay we were
going to give it to the states and we
thought the states were going to rule
the way that we wanted but now turns out
when you give the power to the people
and the right to vote to actually make
their voice heard to say ah we don't
want you to do that then they say okay
you know what you didn't earn this so
now we're you know now we're going to
give it to everyone well it's same thing
in Michigan Michigan Supreme Court put
the uh put the referendum on the ballot
the Republicans were working hard to
take it off the bat because they know
the same thing right is going to happen
in Michigan to happen in Kansas and
state by state they may codify this
right and it may take the right away
from Republicans to oppress the rights
of other people which is not Liberty I
say it every show in the front of the um
it's in the intro yeah the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty now Lindsey Graham
apparently is already backing you know
backing backstepping from his statements
here on on this guy's show let's watch
what these two Traders are saying on
Trader TV News Network I know and North
Korea we all agree on that no wait a
minute now listen I'm not going to sit
on the sidelines and let America become
that kind of nation no one's saying you
need to sit on the sidelines but
yesterday wasn't the day to do that
yesterday was the day they lost all
momentum when this inflation thing
punched him right in the face and you
gave him an out a lot of people don't
like that you could have done it even
Jesse Waters knows what happens here
right they're talking about inflation
they're talking about the market which
is all [ __ ] and here's the reason
why it's [ __ ] is because three
months ago they were yelling and
screaming and Jim Jordan he still
[ __ ] tweeting about gas prices being
eight dollars and they're not eight
dollars they're [ __ ] lying pieces of
[ __ ] yeah let me tell you something if
you want to know the truth don't believe
anything Republicans say or or listen to
what they say and then just think the
opposite right right well because that's
the thing is that yesterday the market
the market came down because inflation
didn't cool off as much as they wanted
but it is cooling which is the whole
point so but the market reacted to it
not cooling as much as they projected it
too because that's what happens in
business and capital and Investments is
they like to plan things slow down Tony
can you spill your role yeah yeah well
you know
slower
[ __ ] Republicans is that oh is that yeah
no I got that okay okay well let's let's
continue here with Lady G and Jesse
Waters Jesse Waters giving him a
spanking other day just like you could
have delayed the whole press conference
like Joe should have delayed that stupid
party it feels like to mean it Lindsey
Graham has the energy when someone finds
out that he has a certain amp on his
phone that he's wandering around
Washington using you know what I'm
saying hey you know what I'm saying I'm
picking up what you're putting down okay
well let's continue uh so I'll take
issue I don't think I don't think
there's a bad day to stand up from The
Unborn what am I trying to say that
America needs to have a policy that
makes us a Civilized Nation it would
bother me that if a baby is aborted at
38 weeks in California New York what am
I proposing for our country that if 15
weeks when the baby can feel pain you
provide anesthesia okay I can't listen
to the Elijah anymore I can't utilize it
anymore it's only 15 week 14 week 18
weeks teen week they keep you know they
keep moving around and they're like this
is a [ __ ] old dude telling people
what the [ __ ] what what is not anything
they would ever experience yeah I I
would never sit and lecture people on
weeks or when the baby or fetus or the
uterus I don't have one I don't know
right stop stop telling other
[ __ ] [ __ ] you don't know
anything about Lindsey Graham Rand Paul
Ted Cruz Mike Lindell Rudy Giuliani shut
the [ __ ] up I mean I guess that's why
he's the bonehead of the week yeah that
would be one and again you know as we'll
see in a moment he really took off yeah
well let's get let's do this
let's give lady G his do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh Lindsey Graham you are a piece of
[ __ ] and you are the bonehead of the
week I love this picture that you have
of him oh yeah that's uh I forget
what interview he did but it's from a
clip where he like licks he just like
like oh God the tongue right now as we
look at it reminds me of the tongue that
was in that dehydrated dinosaur from uh
Jurassic Park right where they go see it
they're like oh yeah when when uh when
it's hanging around yeah
that's a big pile of [ __ ] that's the
moment in the movie that's the Lindsey
Graham moment that's the Lindsey grandma
that is the tongue that because you see
the tongue and then he goes oh that's a
big pile of [ __ ] and boy Lindsay you are
a big pile of [ __ ] everyone thanks for
joining us here on the bone end of the
week every single Friday do not forget
the Tony Michaels podcast every single
Friday on the Midas touch Network and
the Tony Michaels podcast stuck an hour
Friday Friday Friday bone end of the
week come watch it on our Channel at the
Tony Michael pod don't forget to
subscribe there subscribe if you're
watching this on the Midas touch Network
and go follow us on the Tweety tweets
and the trendy trends at Tony Michael's
pod to vote for bonehead of the week
what a great week Gabe everyone have a
great weekend
have a great great weekend we will talk
to you soon this has been this edition
of bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
bone it up the week that was that was
fantastic yeah best best segment there
is I'm glad you there's nothing better
I'm glad you could get your AI self here
um and you know as long as nobody
experience any glitches on my end I
think I think the AI buy is working
pretty good
everyone knows that we recorded this
ahead of time because we did the bone of
the week pull earlier in the week now
thanks thanks for sticking around with
us this week it's been a great week a
lot of news
um and bonehead is always our our
favorite segment and that's why we do it
at the very end they have an explanation
point on the week and don't forget don't
forget to subscribe right here at the
Tony Michaels pod
every single week Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter twitch Simon casting
from Facebook also don't forget man we
got these dark Brandon shirts
summoning the Democratic Powers it is
awesome I you know the red really
because they freaked out about the red I
was like we gotta do a red design I
don't know the red really brings out his
eyes it does he's got great eyes in this
design so go pick up your dark Brandon
merch t-shirts hoodies coffee cups
stickers go to store dot the Tony
michaels.com
store.ttonymichaels.com and get your
favorite dark Brandon merch with our
exclusive design also don't forget to
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify Google leave us a great review
while you're there subscribing Gabe it's
been a great week thanks for kind of
joining us here on Friday even though
it's late Friday but it is for the
audience the audience is ready for them
when they see this so everyone have a
great weekend
Surfs Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
IL born head ass